I have some really strange video for you
today it has been just embarrassing
anecdote after embarrassing anecdote
from the g7 in France for Donald Trump
over the last few days and I really want
to do this thoroughly and that's why the
entire show so far has been g7 related
stuff Donald Trump's only notable
contribution to the g7 as I mentioned
before has been ruining a dinner with
world leaders by insisting that Russia
be added back into the g7 to once again
make it the g8 which it used to be until
2014 he's contributed no ideas to better
the planet he skipped the climate change
meeting he's made no sense in almost
everything he said but the sort of
height or the bottom of this
embarrassing Fiasco was Donald Trump's
explanation of why he wants to add
Russia to the g7 now I'm gonna play the
clip for you it's under 90 seconds in
duration but in the clip Trump attacks
Obama on foreign soil a bad look for
presidents says things that are just
straight-up wrong which is not probably
a shock to you and seems to suggest that
Russia should be back in the g7 because
Putin took Crimea from Ukraine while
Obama was president I know that that
doesn't seem to make any logical sense
because it doesn't make any logical
sense but it seems to be what Donald
Trump is saying let's take a look they
were really it was a President Obama not
blaming him but a lot of bad things
happened with President Putin and
President Obama one of the things that
happened was as you know what happened
in with a very big area a very very big
and important area in the Middle East
where the red line was drawn and then
President Obama decided that he was not
going to do anything about it you can't
draw red lines in the sand you just
can't do it and the other was in Ukraine
having to do with a certain section of
Ukraine that you know very well where it
was sort of taken away from President
Obama not taken away from President
Trump taken away from President Obama
President Obama was not happy that this
happened because it was embarrassing to
him right it was very embarrassing to
him and he wanted Russia to be out of
the
what was called the g8 and that was his
determination he was outsmarted by Putin
he was that smart and President Putin
outsmarted President Obama women and I
can understand how President Obama would
feel he wasn't happy and they're not in
for that reason now I'm only thinking
about the world and I'm thinking about
this country in terms of the g7 whether
it's g7 g8 I think it would be better to
have Russia inside the tent than outside
the tent why doesn't Trump name anything
an important area with a red line Syria
a certain section of Ukraine that you
know well Crimea Putin took Crimea not
from Trump but from Obama
therefore Trump wants Putin back in the
g7 so I'm trying to read between the
lines here I think maybe what Donald
Trump is saying is that Obama screwed up
with Russia Russia took Crimea from
Ukraine under Obama's watch this
embarrassed Obama or it angered Obama
so Obama retaliated by unfairly kicking
Russia out of the then g8 and that
that's a silly reason to have Russia out
so Trump wants them back in basically
what Trump seems to be trying to
articulate in completely failing way is
Obama wanted Russia out and I do the
opposite of Obama
so bring Russia back in now there there
are so many logical contortions or
pretzels here one is not everything that
happens while someone is president is
their fault like is it Donald Trump's
fault or responsibility that Argentina's
economy is crashing even more right now
it's not it's happening wild Trump is
president but not because Donald Trump
is president so that's problem number
one problem number two is that Trump
sort of seems to be saying since Putin
outsmarted Obama and took Crimea from
Ukraine under Obama's watch he doesn't
deserve any punishment for it and
getting kicked out of the g8 was Obama's
Way of punishing him for it or something
like that which is bizarre and then also
remember that Russia was suspended from
the g8
after annexing Crimea on the vote of all
of the other g8 members period
there are many criticisms that we can
make of the g8 or the g7 which are valid
number one they're not doing nearly
enough to fight climate change that's a
very significant and prescient criticism
of the g7 they are perpetuating the
status quo of damaging neoliberal
globalization rather than limiting it
that is a fair and accurate critique of
the g7 they are lacking buy-in from some
major industrialized countries more like
what you see in the g20 but this is not
only childish nonsense that Donald Trump
is adding as I mean I'm calling it a
critique although to call it that
stretches credulity significantly it
also is not even really adding to these
serious critiques that there are of the
g7 and of the ways in which these seven
or the broader g20 nations control so
many aspects of the everyday lives of so
many people on this planet and it's just
it's a waste of time it's a diplomatic
embarrassment and it's a geopolitical
embarrassment quite frankly for
Americans who have to if they understand
what's going on I know the Trump is
defend everything that the guy does but
if you understand what's going on you
see the u.s. embarrassed
day after day press conference after
press conference by Donald Trump and the
sort of height of this is what I want to
talk about next which is that Donald
Trump wants the next g7 at one of his
golf clubs